charming to the last so I'm a little
later getting on this news that I would
like to be but I kind of told myself but
I'm going to try and take the weekend
off and I still kind of am after a
record that I'm not jumping to edit and
upload it immediately but I do still
want to get my thoughts out there on
what the comp word is on what's
happening with Carrie Fisher and
Princess Leia in the Star Wars films so
what obviously I have Carrie Fisher pass
away and it has not had not been planned
for her to pass to pass what obviously I
mean you don't plan on on death her
character was not written out in episode
8 the last Jedi which comes out later
this year and if the word was that she
was supposed to factor rather heavily in
the episode 9 so the big scramble
happened and there were a lot of
questions like are they going to
reproduce her through CGI elected that
would target in Road one are they just
gonna have heard I between episodes are
they going to do reshoots oh that she
dies in episode 8 and we've got a pretty
clear idea of what they're doing now now
we had already known and it was shot
down there not doing CGI Leia like they
did with Tarkin in Road one that is off
the table not happening so that's gone
on episode eight was not reshot or
altered in any way so that Leia dies in
that film so that didn't happen so that
meant that in some fashion her passing
away is going to have to be dealt with
in episode 9 now we've got some more
news on how they're going to deal with
that before I get to that I've just got
to put for it I hadn't talked about it
before my own personal preference
because I talked to a lot of friends
about this I and I heard a lot about it
on various podcast and YouTube videos
that I check out and listen to subscribe
to and what not what I actually think
would have been the best idea is the
thing that a lot of people seem to
dismiss out of hand I actually think the
best approach and it wouldn't have been
ideal but given the circumstances I
think the best approach would have been
to actually have heard I off-screen
between episodes and no you don't just
happen in the column move on you have it
in the crawl but you actually open the
film with her
funeral so that that way you get the
weight of her loss on the story on the
characters and it becomes an appropriate
level of acknowledgment of carrie
fisher's passing that's what I think
would have been the best way to do it
now that's not what they're doing so
word is that she is going to appear in
episode 9 not through CGI not recreate
CGI footage anyways I'm sure they'll be
CGI to put her into backgrounds or
whatever but they're going to be for her
they are going to use existing footage
that was already shot will this work
it's hard to say because it's going to
depend almost entirely on the footage
that they have because depending on what
they have it may be possible to
orchestrate get her into the story and
orchestrate a really fitting send-off
and climax for the character or it may
come across really ham-fisted and really
forced in it could be really bad it's
going to it's got a really hinge on what
they actually have four footage now if
I'm extending some benefit of the doubt
which at this point star wars is kind of
earned from me in terms of what we've
gotten from the film so far and how they
appear to be handling at the franchise
I'll extend some benefit of the doubt I
would like to think that they wouldn't
be doing this approach if they weren't
sure that the footage they have will
work well and they didn't have a plan
for it and my sort of doubling down on
that is the fact that carrie fisher's
kids have signed off on this and i would
also like to think that they wouldn't
have done that if there wasn't a clear
plan and that they knew she was going to
be well represented and properly sent
off because every day they weren't gonna
sign off on the cgi recreation of her so
it seems pretty clear to me that her
kids care about her legacy as an actress
and also add this iconic character so
that gives me some hope that what they
have they could work well with I can't
imagine she's going to be featured very
heavily and the end whether or not
they'll cop to this I have no doubt
there's going to have to be standing at
some point if young
from the back if nothing else so that
they can more easily put her into
situations where you know she wasn't
filmed before so if they're putting it
into this in some way she is going to
pass away as a character in episode 9
whether it is going to be tragic heroic
whether it is going to be something that
she does willfully to save others
whether it is something that it happens
to her I don't know I have a feeling
they're going to go if they were going
to pick some it's gotta be big as Henry
grant it's going to be epic it's going
to be a sacrifice it's going to be
something she chooses to do because just
you know with the character and also not
wanting to sort of repeat the notes of
Hans death um and but given the nature
of lay out the character and also given
the nature of Carrie Fisher as a person
and as an actress I think their natural
inclination is going to be she goes out
on her own terms whatever those end up
being so that's the news an end of it
right now I'm kind of neutral on this
news because what again I still I still
personally feel just opening with her
funeral would have been the best way to
do it but I say that again not knowing
the footage that they have and the
footage that they have good it's
possible could slot perfectly and we
won't know for a little over a year and
a half because this is episode 9 coming
out next no not even next year year
after that so 2019 because we get the
the main numbered entries in the saga
every two years hi guys I forgot exactly
how is the Star Wars release schedule
was working so it's going to be a while
till we find out if what they did is
actually a good idea because I said it's
got a hinge on the footage that they
have but as a plan could work we'll see
what are your thoughts on this latest
sort of wrinkle bit of news in terms of
how Carrie Fisher and Princess Leia are
going to be handled in Star Wars Episode
nine whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
counsel of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is a juror
Oh
[Applause]